club author David Robb documents the
Pentagon's influence on these
entertainment blockbusters and others in
the new book operation Hollywood he
spoke about it recently for about an
hour thank you it's great to be here at
the world headquarters for the center of
skepticism I'm a skeptic myself there's
a lot to be skeptical about these days
Carl Sagan the great astronomer and
philosopher and skeptic once said that
the extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof when I set out to
write this book when I first started
doing the research back in December of
2000 I had heard for years as a reporter
at The Hollywood trade papers that
Hollywood was cooperating with the
military on different movie projects and
TV shows and that if you wanted their
help you had to give them your scripts
and do what they told you so I decided
to see if there was any proof of this
what kind of documentation it was for
this and I love documents on my life
I've been searching for documents it
seems I found back in 1986 I think I
found a Ronald Reagan's federal grand
jury testimony which had been kept
secret for over four to 2530 years when
he was the the Justice Department
suspected him of having taken a bribe
from Lew Wasserman the head of Universal
Studios that paved the way for a
universal to take over the television
industry and I found documents about the
mob corruption in Hollywood Sid korshack
was was the Chicago mafias man in
Hollywood for 50 years there were a lot
of stories about him for variety in The
Hollywood Reporter and I found the
documents about the corrupt Union
official in Hollywood and documents
about the first George Bush when he was
living in Texas in the 1950s I found
on properties that he owned restrictive
covenants that prohibited the sale of
the property to Negroes and Jews had
said I found documents about the a
California Supreme Court Judge Stanley
mosque who had been blackmailed out of
the 1964 a US Senate race by Alan
Cranston Cranston found out that mosque
had a secret life and that there were
photos of him and his girlfriend that
the police the Los Angeles Police
Department's organized crime and tells
us division it had a fella just said hey
do you want these documents he had the
Marion Phillips had been the head of the
LAPD's ocid unit for many years and he
died and given all his documents to a
friend he said you want these documents
I said sure so I met him at a Denny's
parking lot and we just loaded him in
the back of my car but so I went back to
Washington DC to see if there were any
documents about this Hollywood Pentagon
connection and sure enough there were
thousands of pages of documents showing
the 50-year history of the collaboration
between Hollywood in the military these
are some of the documents up here some
my favorite documents I was back there
in December of 2000 at the very time
that the the election was going on the
contested election presidential election
and I was back there when Gore resigned
and gave and the Supreme Court ruling
gave Bush the presidency
I don't normally believe in conspiracies
I don't believe in UFO conspiracies and
I don't believe in JFK assassination
conspiracies but there are some
conspiracies there really are
conspiracies one is the organized crime
is a real conspiracy it by its very
nature it's organized and it's a
conspiracy to corrupt the regular
businesses and the government and the
police and the judicial system this is
another real conspiracy there's been a
conspiracy going on for 50 years
between the world's most powerful
military and the world's most powerful
medium to put propaganda into American
films and television shows one of my
earlier doc earliest documents the dates
back to 1953 during the making of the
movie battle cry it was written by Leon
URIs and I was fortunate enough to
interview Leon Shirley before he died
and the movie told the story of a eight
Marines who were on their way from boot
camp to Guadalcanal during World War two
and one of the guys that was assigned
with him was a Navy medic and in the
script his name was a Pedro the the
script was written and the film was
actually shot and then the the Marine
Corps had big reservations about the
speech that the Pedro gave Pedro was a
Hispanic character in the movie was
played by the great Hispanic actor
Victor Milan who was in so many great
movies he was in in this movie he had a
speech he was the the constantly during
the film the but one of the characters
in the film where the other Marines
played by fess parker was accusing him
of being a [ __ ] and a Mexican and all
kinds of very racist comments and at one
point they get into a fight in a bar
scene and their friends separate him and
then Pedro gives his uh his dialog and
this here is the the actual document
that I found in the in the and the
records that the Pentagon had donated
all of thousands and thousand boxes
hundreds of boxes of documents to the
Georgetown University Library and their
Special Collections Archives I went back
there and spent weeks back there going
to these and this is one of the
documents they found this is an actual
blow-up of the page from the speech and
this is Pedro speech and in the NF and
the the the margins here the marine
corps censor wrote the word and
underlined twice Terra
and Pedro speeches as that is why Pedro
sir because for the first time in my
life I've been treated as a man there
are none New Zealand he's and there's no
racism there he wasn't subjected to I
can walk into a restaurant right a
streetcar sit in movies
no one stares at me here the people they
they call me texts like I'm a real Texan
no one here knows what a [ __ ] is I want
you to know my friends Pedro does not
fight for democracy because Pedro has no
democracy I come into the service to
learn medicine so I can go back to my
rotten shack town in Texas and keep the
little ones from dying of Filth
I am sorry some of I'm sorry I came to
New Zealand because I know I must return
to Texas well the the Commandant of the
Marine Corps so this was a terrible
speech that this was going to be and I
have this this is the this is the actual
document the where the Commandant from
the common of the Marine Corps so it
says here suggest modification of the
paragraph which starts this is why Pedro
is sorry he came this speech by Pedro
would not only be objectionable to
Texans but Americans as well any rights
it would also be put to good use by
communists who are sure to use it out of
context so what happened was they cut
this speech out of the picture and then
they realized that without this speech
none of the the previous scenes that the
Victor Malan the actor had been in made
any sense including the very last scene
of the movie where when Pedro was killed
after receiving the Silver Star and he's
killed fess parker the racist character
and his buddies they all come to the
gravesite and fess parker has the
emotional climax of the film where he
says well i guess is too late to
apologize to pedro now so hidden so
without this they cut out every piece of
Pedro he's a victor Milan who had been
in the film throughout the picture is no
because they cut the scene they had to
cut
all the other scenes and he's now he
disappeared from the film entirely the
day before the the screening at the
Pantages Theatre in 1953 he got a call
from his agent saying well there's good
news and bad news the good news is that
you're invited to the premiere tonight
the bad news is that you're not in the
picture and for 50 years he never knew
what happened they never told him what
happened and I tracked him down and I
went and interviewed him I showed him
the documents and just the last year I
showed him the doctrines for the first
time he understood why he had been
killed all this picture he never knew
that's the human face of what the
military is doing actually he was he was
really devastated by this loss of this
role was a great role for Hispanic actor
at that time and and he never knew what
had happened but this is not even though
this is a holdover from the Cold War era
it's not just something that's relegated
to the past that's happening today just
about 10 miles down the road if you go
down Wilshire get to Westwood at the
corner of Wilshire and Westwood
boulevards there's a a big tall office
building on the 11th floor is an entire
floor housing the Army Navy Air Force
Marine Corps and Coast Guard film
offices were staffed with people who do
nothing but look at movie scripts and
television scripts and with their little
green pencils and marking taking things
out and putting things in and if you
want the military's airplanes and ships
and helicopters and tanks you have to do
what they say you have to take it out
negotiate an agreement with them and
then they assign a minder to be on the
set at all times to make sure that you
shot the the sequence of the military
sequences exactly as you agreed to do it
which is very difficult in the
filmmaking process which is films often
are shot from a script of course but
throughout the making the movie they're
changing the script every day
and if you have to ask the military to
make it to make a change it's really
empathetic of the whole filmmaking
process it really messes up the works
and so they have huge fights over over
what can stay and what can go and
there's one top army major David George
I who's been an army minder on numerous
film said that if if they don't do what
I say I just take my toys and go home
and which is cost that can shut down a
film's production it can custom millions
of dollars it can be a big mess the
military does this is very they're very
candid in their documents are very
candid about why they do this to a point
they say that they do this to the they
will cooperate with a producer if they
believe that it will help in the
retention and recruitment of personnel
they want the military to look good they
say so that the people will join the
army or the Navy or the Marine Corps
they over the last 50 years hundreds of
films have gone through the military's
approval approval process leaving the
Pentagon's
cutting room floor graveyard of cut
scenes and dialogue and and an entire
movies have even been not been made
because they couldn't get military
cooperation and the military even
targets children they they've rewritten
and censored the episodes of lassie the
Mickey Mouse Club very proudly they
actually I've got documents on The
Mickey Mouse Club than Alaska that they
changed and to make the military more
attractive to children again a good
example this targeting children occurred
in the 1980 during the making of the
right stuff the great movie about the
the early days of the space race the
original script had was filled with
vulgarity and cussing and foul language
and
an Air Force colonel who is the head of
the Public Affairs Office of the Air
Force's Los Angeles office wrote a
letter to the film's producer expressing
his concern that unless the film's
producers cleaned up the the language it
would receive an R rating meaning that
no one under 17 would be admitted unless
accompanied by a parent he wrote in the
document which I have here says the
obscene language used seems to guarantee
in our rating if distributed as an art
cuts down on the teenage audience which
is a prime one to the military services
when recruiting goals are considered so
the of course the producers needed their
stuff so they cut the language and it
got a PG rating and lots of kids got to
see the movie I think if you ask most
soldiers or sailors or Marines I haven't
really done a study this this is I don't
have a document on this but many of them
would tell you that they saw some movie
that made them want to join the service
so the guy a terrific guy who is the
head of the Marine Corps film ops and
marine Courage's are just fantastic guys
the film office fantastic guys they gave
me unlimited access to their documents I
went to the marine Kirsten office they
spent a month going through their
documents they had a guy staying there
watching me the entire time great guy
sergeant homestead but the other
services oh no you have to go through
the formation act you have to file forms
and then they wouldn't give me any of
the documents I wanted when I asked them
what I want I want to see the documents
where you tell the producers to take out
pieces of the script they said we can't
show you that because the scripts have
copyrights in any mentions of
copyrighted materials also cooperated
well that is actually not the law but
that's how they interpret it but the
Marine Corps were very we're very open
and the captain now major Matt Morgan
said we have nothing to hide and
and they were very open and so I spent
the two months in the Marine Corps film
office and and the Marine Corps no
matter how good of guys they are they
still do some pretty terrible things to
movies they're not filmmakers the head
of the Pentagon's film office is a fella
named Phil Strube he's back in
Washington DC and he he is a former
thinking with the USC or UCLA film
school he wanted to be a filmmaker I
serve a frustrated filmmaker now he is
in charge of saying what goes in what
stays in the movies that the military
cooperates with the Marine Corps one the
most shocking documents that I found was
was a movie uh cul de The Great Santini
there was a scene in the movie starring
Robert Duvall Oh sir this wild and crazy
retiring em Marine Corps jet pilot who
is having trouble sort of integrating
himself back into his family as he's
getting ready to retire his big
prankster and one of the jokes at he and
one of his buddies wanted to do was to
go to the boot camp were there some
young recruits are going to the Marine
Corps boot camp and they wanted to
pretend to kill a they had a drill
instructor pretending to be a recruit
and they pretended to kill him and then
make the other kids throw this body into
the dumpster and the idea for this was
that the the drill instructor would
would get the kids to do whatever he
told him to do it was a very funny scene
the military though doesn't have a sense
of humor especially when it comes to
jokes about killing recruits it's bad
for recruitment
so they said no that has to go the
producer pleaded with them he said I
have the documentary says this is the
funniest seeing the picture but I
understand that to meet your recruiting
goals this might not be helpful so we
reluctantly agree to cut it it was a
nine page scene that was cut out of the
picture this is a picture that was
nominated for an Oscar for a screenplay
didn't win it
who knows if the funniest scene had been
in the picture it might have had a
better chance but the military doesn't
care about Oscars
the fellow the the military is not the
only one that has a film offices the
State Department has a film office the
CIA has a film obviously I'll try to
influence the images that you see in
motion pictures and television shows but
the the military is the only one that
really has the leverage they have the
tanks the planes the guns the locations
the personnel the stuff the others the
CIA all they have is a symbol on the
floor of the logic come in and shoot
that but otherwise they don't have
anything to to bribe filmmakers with and
I interviewed chase Brandon who was the
head of the CIA's film office and he was
very jealous Lee said we'll fill Strube
at the pentagon he can actually say I
want page six and page seven completely
thrown out or you don't get your to use
our aircraft carrier and that's what
they do they can tell you to take out
page six and page seven over the you
know there's recently there's been a lot
of Americans were shocked at the images
that they've seen from American soldiers
torturing Iraqi prisoners and I'm sort
of surprised really not really surprised
but it's interesting that so many people
are were stunned by this but what I was
thinking that maybe one reason their
stuffs so surprised by it is because all
these images have been sanitized by by
the the military when when the military
cooperates with a with a film producer
they make them take out any suggestions
hints or even jokes about work
or are torturing of prisoners this
happened this happened in 1967 on the
movie Green Berets there was a scene in
which John Wayne was who was played the
Colonel Kirby in the picture was his a
standing by approvingly as a South
Vietnamese officer tortures a Vietcong
prisoner and the Marine Corps said this
has to go we can't have this it'll make
it look like is actually the State
Department told the Marine Corps first
that the state farmer reviewed the
script and found said that it would
might increase like the Frances Tully
who was a high-ranking department of
state official till the Pentagon
film office the brutality shown toward a
prisoner of the Vietnamese officer and
the approval by the Americans including
Colonel Kirby John Wayne who is in
command is grist for the opponents of US
policy in Vietnam and suggests some of
the accusations of these opponents
against the US and is of course a clear
violation of the Articles of War
never mind that these kind of things
really happen American troops actually
through Vietcong prisoners out of
helicopters they were tortured we know
today that these kind of things did
happen but the State Department didn't
want it and so the Pentagon passed along
the word and the scene was cut there's
so many examples of this on the movie
Windtalkers which came out 2002 there
was a scene in in this original script
in which a character called the dentist
after a war in the in the Pacific after
a battle he's seen creeping along the
battlefield with a band that and going
to the corpses of dead Japanese soldiers
and trying out the gold fillings out of
their mouths I have
from the national archives actual
footage of a Marine Corps doing this not
with a bayonet but with a pair of pliers
and he's actually pulling out the gold
teeth this really happened the Marine
Corps told them to have a memo up here
saying this has to go so the they talked
about in a course it went there was
another scene in which the the lead
character in the picture of the hero
Nicolas Cage is seen blasting a
surrendering and wounded Japanese
soldier with a flamethrower the United
States military it's against the
Articles of War to kill surrendering
soldiers and so the Pentagon told them
this has to go and of course that also
went there was a Marine Corps the the
military doesn't even like jokes about
atrocities there was a film of you and
back in 1980 called stripes with Bill
Murray a comedy that would have been
much funnier without the military's
involvement the there was a scene where
the couple the characters are joking
about their raping and pillaging well
there's I have a document the military
says raping and pillaging has to go and
of course it went but it's a lot of it
is about recruiting they do target they
do target people for recruiting and for
people who are too old to be recruited
people like me and some of you here they
have a term for us we're called
influencers they try to influence us so
that we will influence younger people
and our nephews and sons and daughters
and say yes I saw a movie I think the
Marine Corps is a great thing for a
great opportunity they also try to
influence Congress they made your George
I the one of the chief minders for the
army film office told me that that they
target the these films to Congress
because congressmen he says go to movies
too when they see positive
the military they're more likely to
spend 500 billion dollars a year to to
fund the military and I think there have
been some hopefully unintended
consequences I think I don't have a
document on this there's no Pentagon
document that says this but 50 50 years
ago or 60 years ago now or even more in
1940 when the German army was rolling
over Europe and attacking England the
American people would not go to war they
had to be a attacked first today after
50 years of propaganda being put into
the movies and TV shows American people
are willing to go to war at the drop of
a hat even without being and attacked
ourselves I don't know if how much that
has to do with it but I can't help but
think that the 50 years of being
saturated with military propaganda has
had no effect on the American character
there are there are people who've stood
up against the the military and refused
to do what the do their bidding some
some really great filmmakers artists
Clint Eastwood back when he was making
Heartbreak Ridge back in 1983-84 he he
one of them the military's cooperation
and he gave him the script and they made
all their suggestions he said okay and
there was a scene in the picture in
which at the very end where Clint
Eastwood walks up and summarily shoots a
wounded Cuban soldier this was on the
island of Grenada this is the movie
about the invasion of Grenada and they
said no lettuce ago you have to take
that out we can't have Americans
soldiers shooting
the combatants it's a war crime well he
refused to take it out and he and when
they screened it for the Pentagon when
you after you make your movie with the
Pentagon cooperation you have to
actually screen it for the Pentagon you
have to show it to him before it's
released the public they said hey you
you you you didn't take that out he says
well I just thought of where you were
giving me a suggestion I didn't know I
had to do what you say I said no you
have to do it well I'm not taking it out
so they gave he had a huge fight with
the Pentagon over this and especially
with the Robert Sims who was the the
Assistant Secretary of Defense for
public affairs and and Eastwood accused
Simms in a letter they have of trying to
threaten you to shut down production
right in the middle because he wouldn't
do what they said he got his movie made
but he said he would never work with
them again as long as Simms was the
assistant secretary fans and there's a
movie field of fire that never filled a
fire never got made it was based on a
book by James Webb who was the former
Secretary of the Navy he'd been a
Vietnam veteran saw firsthand
experiences of burning down villages
soldiers fragging their own officers
means shooting and killing their own
officers smoking pot and and numerous
war crimes that he documented the
military said they would not help him
and this was a former Secretary of the
Navy based on his own true experience
they would not help him in his this film
has never been made because he couldn't
get it he couldn't get it made without
their assistance there's also I think a
very serious constitutional issue with
regard to all this and that is that the
First Amendment says that the Congress
shall make no law abridging the freedom
of speech but Congress oversees the
budget for the for the Pentagon the
Pentagon cannot do what Congress cannot
do the Pentagon cannot abridge
freedom speech either and I've talked to
many legal experts including the famed
First Amendment attorney Floyd Abrams
and renowned constitutional law
professor Erlin Chemerinsky here at USC
say this is the violation First
Amendment Floyd Abrams you may remember
was the co-counsel for the New York
Times in the and agon Papers case and he
told me that this sort of viewpoint
based discrimination by the government
in which it favors one form of speech
over another is flatly inconsistent with
the First Amendment so that if you he's
saying that it's unconstitutional for
for the for the government or the
Pentagon to say and to give favors to
speech that they like if you play ball
with them and make a movie that they
like they'll help you but if you make a
movie like like Oliver Stone critical of
the military critical of war anti-war
films they won't help you that is a
clear violation of the First Amendment
Abrams said there there are two types of
limitations on speech by the government
that are especially subject suspect the
first involves limitations on speech by
the government that are the first
involves limitations based on the
subject being discussed for example if
the army said we don't want any movies
about the army see we won't help anyone
who is making a film about the army that
would be a limitation on the subject
that would be constitutionally suspect
but the second category of speech is
even more disturbing from any First
Amendment perspective that is a
limitation on speech based upon the
viewpoint expressed by the speaker so if
the army says we will cooperate with
some filmmakers but only ones which
please us because of the position it
takes about the armed forces that is
even more clearly unconstitutional
professor Chemerinsky here's a great
first minute expert at USC he said that
the Supreme Court has said that above
all the first of them means that the
government cannot participate in
viewpoint discrimination the government
cannot favor some speech due to its
viewpoint and disfavor others because of
its viewpoint the court has said that
when the government is given
financial benefits it can't decide who
to give it to or not to give it to based
on the viewpoint expressed well that's
exactly what the Pentagon does every day
I asked the Abrams and Chemerinsky well
why is this still going on and they both
said because no one is sued if any
lawyers here tonight there is a plenty
of Supreme Court cases on this subject
not on this the Pentagon but on the the
right of the the unconstitutionality of
the government favoring one form of
speech or another and rosenberger versus
university of virginia 1995 case a US
Supreme Court ruled that that quote it
is axiomatic that the government may not
regulate speech based on its substantive
content or the message it conveyed in
the realm of private speech or
expression government regulation may not
favor one speaker over another so it's
pretty clear that the Pentagon does
favor one speaker of another and the
fellow who wrote my book Jonathan Turley
who's a professor a constitutional law
professor at the George Washington
University he believes that this is a
that this really should be something
that Congress looks at that Congress has
the oversight over the military he
doesn't think that the current Supreme
Court would rule against the military in
this but he thinks that Congress should
look at this that Congress should hold
hearings on this they're a little busy
right now but maybe when they get them
searching the Iraqi prisoners they can
take a look at the what the Pentagon is
torturing the movies and television
shows some of the stories are very funny
- II I thought maybe I'd read a chapter
a short chapter from the book about
stripes
when you watch a film on videocassette a
little disclaimer usually pops up on the
screen before the movie starts saying
this film has been modified to fit the
format of your screen you were told this
obvious little bit of information but
you aren't told that the film has been
modified by the military in an effort to
get you to join the army as was the case
with stripes the screwball comedy
starring Bill Murray and Harold Ramis
has lowlife misfits who join the army
ended up becoming heroes Dan Goldberg
the film's producer and co-writer was
candid about the film's recruiting
potential when he sent the script to the
Pentagon asking for their assistance and
he wrote this our intention in producing
stripes is to make a comedy film with
patriotic overtones that would hopefully
have a positive effect on Army
Recruiting he wrote on September 10th
1980 and a letter to Don Baruch was in
the head of the Pentagon's film office
Goldberg wanted to shoot his movie at
Fort Knox the army base in Kentucky he
wanted dozens of tanks and c-140
transport planes and he would and he
would need over 100 real soldiers to
work as extras in the movie in return he
promised the army he'd make a movie
they'd be proud of that he writes this
although there will be certain amount of
humor and parity in this film the
overall intent is not to portray the
army as a collection of aberrant
personalities he wrote the story is
basically about how a platoon of misfits
are transformed into a platoon of army
heroes our intention is to portray the
army as realistically and posit
positively as possible the 30 rope they
don't teach that in film school that a
comedy should have a certain amount of
humor and parity but that in that but
that its overall intent should be to
portray the military in a positive light
the army however was skeptical they're
skeptics too
they weren't sure that Goldberg would
play ball they didn't think that he'd be
willing to change the script enough to
make it the end of the kind of
recruiting poster they wanted but they
were wrong
Lieutenant Colonel Richard Griffin's I'm
sorry Griffiths chief of the Army's
publican plans division laid out his
concerns and a memo to superiors in the
Army's Directorate of Defense
Information he wrote before we could
recommend supporting stripes he wrote
extensive rewrites would be necessary
before the script could be acceptable
and in the process would probably
destroy the comedic intent he was right
about that the film would have to be
rewritten literally from beginning to
end in the original screenplay the first
image to be shown on the screen was to
have been of a wacky Army Recruiting add
that Bill Murray is watching while
getting his shoe shined it's this ad
that gives him the idea to enlist the
army however didn't think the parody of
one of its recruiting edge was very
funny would have to go quote the the
recruiting ads on TV would have to be
changed to a more broadly comedic style
or deleted entirely the colonel said in
his August 29th memo
no problem Goldberg replied a week later
in a letter to Baruch he wrote quote
army recruiting ad we will either use a
real army add or drop it from the script
in the end of the yep did they use a
real army recruiting ad which is used
which is used to open the film roof it's
also said that the filmmakers have to
eliminate the depiction of drug use in
the barracks and during the recruits
graduation ceremony if they wanted the
Army's cooperation the scenes of never
ending supplies of drugs in the barracks
would have to be changed he wrote no
problem Goldberg told the army all drugs
and drug references will be removed from
the preparation of the graduation and
the graduation itself he wrote is reply
in fact drug use is eliminated from the
picture altogether the army also wanted
Goldberg
tone down the character of Sergeant
Hulka the drill sergeant played by
warren oates who enjoys torturing the
recruits again no problem quote sergeant
Hulka will be less sadistic in tone
throughout the script goldberg wrote in
his letter to the army he also promised
at the army he also promised the army
did he would rewrite the chain the
character of general barnicke II who was
depicted as a foul-mouthed commanding
officer in the original script then he
writes Colonel general barnicke he will
be played straighter without the
continuous obscenities goldberg told the
army Indian burn Aki was has only a few
lines nothing played for laughs and none
of them containing any obscenities the
amorite also didn't want any scenes in
like the and the original script that
showed a Bill Murray and his squad of
misfits taking part in a combat
readiness mission in Mexico
quote the scenes dealing with the trip
to Mexico and South America with the
counter-guerrilla troops must be
rewritten to delete any references to
counter guerrilla troops and/or army
operations in Mexico or any other South
American country the army said in its
memo again Goldberg complied there will
be no references to Mexico he told the
army they were referred to combat
readiness missions as down south in the
end the scene although shot was edited
out of the film altogether the army also
wanted Goldberg to eliminate a bit of
dialogue in which one of the soldiers
joked about raping and pillaging again
Goldberg complied references on rape and
pillages will be deleted he he wrote the
army had numerous other suggestions the
sexism should be eliminated throughout
the script they wrote the character of
psycho and Elmo would have to be changed
to a more broadly committee style or
deleted entirely in the end the army was
satisfied with all the changes the
Goldberg agreed to make and the script
and granted them full cooperation then
is a quote here from the letter this is
to advise you officially that stripes
has been approved
assistance authorized for filming at
Fort Knox Brooke told wrote in a letter
dated October 30th 1982 Sheldon Schrager
head of production at Columbia Pictures
which was producing film mr. Goldenberg
has been most cooperative Andrus and
responded quickly to Army Department of
Defense requests for changes indeed
Baruch was so happy with the final
shooting script that he told Schrager
quote if the picture is a success as
successful as we all hope and believe it
will be remember the ending leaves it
open for a sequel trigger also couldn't
have been more pleased with the studio's
collaboration with the military quote as
we discussed on the phone he ruined the
letter to Baruch in 1980 I really
believe the stripes will be the ushering
end of a new era of cooperation between
motion picture producers especially
Columbia and the Department offense may
it be that all producers are as
cooperative as Ivan Reitman and Dan
Goldberg are in making changes in their
script so that it becomes feasible on
everybody's part we realize your
problems and we need your help together
we can make a lot of pictures that will
be beneficial to all indeed the film
produced the results that both sides
desired it made a lot of money for the
studio and increased recruitment for the
army quote mr. Goldberg told me this
interview I was I was told by the army
after the movie came out that their
recruiting went up after stripes came
out he said I don't know if that is a
good thing or bad thing by the way so I
asked him so why did he tell the
military that the that his intention and
producing stripes is to make a comedy
film with a patriotic overtones it would
be hopefully have a positive effect on
Army Recruiting Goldberg now says quote
I was trying to assuage their
nervousness about that this would be a
negative portrayal of the army he also
claims that the script changes he didn't
demanded by the army did not hurt the
film but made it better
it was very painless he says of the of
the script approval process they had a
few suggestions on the script they
didn't a sense of the script they wanted
the military seems to be accurate him to
the military we embraced the realism
that they required we felt that the more
real the army was the more comedy we
could get and as a corollary you would
probably have the the field that the
army was a place to join now that's what
I wanted not not that that's what I
wanted necessarily he said in fact the
Pentagon's own documents show that the
army was less interested in realism
actually than it was in making sure that
the movie portrayed the military in a
positive light no sexism in the army no
no drugs no mistreatment of recruits
it's just a good place to start to be
all that you can be in fact the military
doesn't care about accuracy at all but
there was a great example this is from
the film 13 days Kevin Costner starred
in co-starred and produced it was about
the Cuban Missile Crisis as look just a
few years ago the the script was a it
had one fictitious character that they
had that was Costner's character but the
rest of film was based entirely on
historical events and and indeed on the
John Kennedy in the White House before
Richard Nixon was taping John Kennedy
also had a taping system in the Oval
Office and during all the conferences
with the drenches of stuff on what to do
about the Cuban Missile Crisis these
these are hidden recorders recorded
everything including Curtis LeMay saying
that we have to bomb and attack Cuba and
that when Kennedy decided instead to put
up a naval blockade the Curtis LeMay was
overheard saying that this is the worst
sell out since Munich clearly the Joint
Chiefs of Staff wanted to go
war to invade and to attack into and we
now know that the Cuba had thanks 70 or
80 armed nuclear missiles that would
have probably triggered World War three
and that the Kennedy standing up to the
military and his advisers took us down
the different paths but the military
said no you have to change the script
you have to make the the the generals
lost bellicose and to their credit the
producers Peter almond and Kevin caution
refused to do this and because of this
they had to go to the Philippines
because they couldn't get American
aircraft that they needed for the flight
scenes and they had there to rinse him
old 1960 era jet fighters from the that
were just in mothballs really had to
paint him up and pull them around with
tractors on the tarmac and and and do
special effects to make it look like
they were flying so so in another sense
the Pentagon is is increasing a runaway
production if you can't make it or you
have to take it go overseas to make a
movie because the military won't help
you here but sometimes that's not even
an option because sometimes the military
puts pressure on foreign militaries to
stop your picture there was a talk to
Taylor Hackford on an officer and a
gentleman and there was so much so many
script changes that they wanted to make
and and he also stood up against Massino
they wanted they thought that it made
the the Philippines government look bad
they thought that that made they thought
this would hurt relationships with the
the film beat Philippine government
causes a scene in there early in the
picture well there's a flashback to to
the youth of the the actor and so when
he Taylor Hackford and the producer
ask the the Canadian snowbirds which is
the connect Canada's equivalent of the
Blue Angels if they would help him they
found out that the the Pentagon had
called the Canadian military and told
them don't do it so they said they made
a big protest to the Reagan Reagan was
President Reagan was president then and
they protested this but nothing ever
came of it and they never did get this
Nady Canadian snowbirds but once again
the Marine Corps who are great guys said
well we're not supposed to do this
because the Pentagon has denied
cooperation but if you set your camera
up at a certain place at a certain time
a couple of planes might fly over real
low which they did yeah it helped the
movie so just a couple of the documents
up here might the this is a clear and
present danger this was from 1993 they
had a lot of problems with this picture
if first the the producers would would
not cooperate and finally they they
agreed to do everything the military
said the script has been revised to
reflect Department Vince concerns
regarding military command and control
recognition of Colombian sovereignty and
an improved depiction of the presidency
[Music]
special operations doctor operation have
been made credible military personnel
are realistically portrayed and military
equipment and weapons systems are
quickly intelligently properly used in
short military depictions have become
more of a commercial for us and that's
what it's really about they want movies
have been made into commercials for the
military
this is a this is a film this is from a
film that was written by a friend of
mine the great blacklisted writer Bernie
Gordon he it's a Hellcats of the Navy
it's the only film that Ronald and Nancy
Reagan Reverend together ironically we
know from from history that the last
film that Ronald rate that the President
Kennedy ever saw before he was
assassinated was 55 days at Peking which
Bernie Gordon wrote under the blacklist
under different name and we also know
that the film that Lee Harvey Oswald was
watching in the Dallas Theater when he
was arrested was called cry of battle
which was also written by Bernie Gordon
and this film helped catch the Navy this
document says that the government and
return for letting them use a submarine
on this picture the the Pentagon expects
certain reciprocity in script changes
and that basically is tells the story of
the of the entire they expect script
changes in return for their stuff and
they get them
I guess if there are any questions get
c2 out there
over here I was just wondering um well
we know about from what you said the
influence of the military on moviemaking
and the censorship what about the other
way around what about the conscious and
unwitting or witting complicity of the
movie studios with the military I mean
does it go the other way around as well
yes a very good question the question is
is other movie studios complicit with
the with the military is not just a
one-way street and exactly right this is
not just the military doing this this is
also Hollywood is doing this Hollywood
is selling out their audience in
exchange for saving me a few bucks in
their budget they are collaborators in
the worst sense of the word of the word
the Writers Guild of America which has
the its job is to its stated goal is
protect the the creative and economic
interests of writers has done nothing
about this in 50 years they never filed
one complaint the studio's put pressure
on the on the producers to make these
changes to save money the MPAA and Jack
Valenti actually screen of these films
for the Pentagon at their offices the
the Hollywood is this is this is a both
sides I believe are a couple on this but
they both receive benefits and that's
why they want to keep this going for as
long as they can
yeah I recently saw Tim Robbins great
play embedded which is now New York
about the control the military has over
journalism in Iraq and I wonder how this
relates to your side of the of the
cinema story and if you see this as a
giant leap forward in the military
control of what the American people get
to see well what the the military is
about besides making war which they're
good at and movies routes are not good
at as control and and the military likes
to control information and the images
and the control of news is very
disturbing because we expect the to get
news that is not censored by the
military but I think it's equally
troubling that when the military is
controlling art and I believe that film
and television is art even though some
of its bad art it's still are done when
that the the military is controlling art
and that the the viewers don't even know
that they're being manipulated it's it's
very it's very disturbing I think there
they go hand in hand news and art it's
information that they're trying to
control yes there's a movie called
classic of circa 1969 called the gay
deceivers with Kevin Coughlin
it's a beat type of flick that kind of
gut by the military do you know even in
view of this you know if the military in
your research have sought to suppress a
movie that like the gay deceivers got
away from them yeah the John
[Music]
John Ford made a great movie right after
World War two is a documentary actually
called let there be light
and this showed he went into a rebuilt
rehabilitation hospital where where
soldiers were suffering from what they
called shell shock or post-traumatic
stress disorder and they were trembling
and shaking and stuttering and really
horrible effects of psychological
effects of going to the war and this was
this is a wonderful and fantastic
exploration of the psychological effects
of war on people military saw the
picture and it was so disturbing that
they banned it from being shown in the
United States for 35 years it only
became they only release into the into
the public domain about ten years ago
and and a funny story is that the the
producers of a film called Maria's
lovers which was they wanted to show
make a movie a feature film about a
returning soldier who was
psychologically injured and they'd asked
the military gee could we'd like to use
a minute of the let there be light to
open our film and the military lied to
them and and and led them to believe
even though it was now in the public
domain after 35 years they'd finally
released it and was in the public domain
it was open to anybody to use it the
military sent them letters obfuscating
and misleading them and making them
think that they could not use this
finally they wised up were able to use
it but no thanks to the military yeah
the military will try to but that's rare
that there's very few the the Pentagon
does not really ban films although they
cannot just come and say no you can't
make that picture that's they don't do
that
yes I was wondering if with the advent
of cheap GCI
CGI excuse me and the ability of
producers to make their own toy so to
speak if this is a problem that might
sometime unfairly view your future go
away I would hope so I would hope that
the economics of it would would that the
CGI would allow producers to make their
pictures with without the military but
it's never going to be as cost-effective
it's never going to be is as realistic
as shooting on a real aircraft carrier
there's just nothing like the real thing
so I expect this to keep going unless
somebody does something about it could
you go into a little more detail about
the Mickey Mouse censorship that seems a
bit distant from military goals yeah
yeah see to last chip the question was a
little more detail on The Mickey Mouse
Club in lassie I don't have those
documents here they're really hilarious
the Mickey Mouse Club they used to
produce these shows called Mouse reels
their little documentaries that would be
on the show and they would go out and
shoot children doing different things
not actually shoot children film
children and one of the episodes they
did a lot with the military that a lot
of these Mouse reels were done with the
military they went over to Honolulu and
they'd gone down a blimp and they and
one of the the trips they took was on
the USS Nautilus the first nuclear
submarine and I had the script for the
for this this this episode and the the
military it was a cute little story
about these kids going on this ship and
the military was raving oh this is going
to be a great way to introduce a whole
new generation to the to the nuclear
Navy and the script was changed in
several places to make it look like this
is a the nuclear submarines were
children friendly really it was just
amazing and then
and one of the screw one of the lines in
the script was it and and and this is
one of the problems when you know that
the military is looking over your
shoulder at your script that you're
going to put on the air and you know
that you need their cooperation there's
a certain amount of self-censorship that
start structure in the beginning and
there's no documentation on that but you
know that they're watching you got to
make them happy you're going to put with
it what you want in there and they
actually wrote in the script that that
on board the ship this could food and
there's good there's hardly no radiation
then and the the the sailors favorite
show was the Mickey Mouse march on the
jukebox
so it's nuclear submarines are very
kid-friendly for lassie there was they
they had a couple of episodes was they
they asked for military assistance
lassie of course was the dog who was
always saving the day saving people and
one of the the in one of the episodes
there was a Timmy the little boy who
owned lassie had set up a contraption
are going to try to out of an old radio
in some parts and try to draw down a
flying saucer and they turned it on and
nothing seemed to happen then all of a
sudden lassie started barking and and
this airplane crashed and they're in
there and though in the woods there by
their Shack and they thought that
somehow they made this happen so the the
army came and was looking around and and
they said well we want to take lassie
back to there and do some experiments at
this wind tunnel and and they set up the
suit what had crashed was that was a
reconnaissance plane an army
reconnaissance plane and they did the
wind tunnel and then less he started
barking saw that shows that she heard
this ultrasonic sound that a vibration
was caused in the wing that caused the
plane to crash and she was the only one
to know it now she solved the problem
that we can fix the airplane and no one
else will be killed because lassie saved
the day military said no you can't have
that
just make it icing on the wing and you
know instead of
a defective military equipment just make
it unforeseen conditions and so they
changed the whole script and then it
changed the whole story - because lassie
no longer saves the day she solved the
mystery but she doesn't save the day in
the original script she had save future
people from being killed by this
defective part but now it's just icing
you know and that was that was the love
there are a couple other lassie ones are
pretty funny hi do you foresee the day
when Congress will require that such
movies contain a notification at the
beginning to the effect that this film
has been approved for public viewing by
the Department of Defense or yeah maybe
if we get a Democratic Congress in 2005
yeah the no I I think I I think I would
I would be off for that but all the the
Congress all the the the labels that are
on films now are are put there by by the
creative community by the Directors
Guild with a Writers Guild something
like that would have to be put on I
can't see the the Congress doing that I
would see that more something maybe the
Writers Guild should ask for that this
film has been changed to meet the
recruiting requirements of the US
military
thank you thank you very much David Rob
is a freelance journalist operation
Hollywood is published by Prometheus
books visit Prometheus books com
for more information you're watching
book TV on cc